[Applause]
okay we're back with karen the amazing
mom of two boys and
she's looking for a little design advice
um
and uh i would love to give you some
yeah i mean clearly i need it look at
that
well by the way you had a big other
change happened too recently
yeah yeah so 2020 again
kind of the year of change for me i went
into it
and it was like okay i'm gonna turn 40
this year i
joined the gym in january then of course
those got closed down in march
uh workout videos thankfully exist and
yeah i've lost about 75 pounds this year
so far in like
nine some months thank you
thank you i feel good i feel good and
that's
what matters and my kids get to see that
that's the other thing they'll talk all
the time mommy you're so strong you're
so strong and
i knew i was strong mentally with
everything i've gone through but now
it's sort of ready to show people yeah
i'm i'm also physically strong i mean at
just
every single turn you are such
an inspiration i can't handle it it's
like
karen what can't you do
i mean i'm pretty sure we can find so
we'll design a bedroom clearly
well i'm not good at that good news
karen
i'm getting on my little design cape and
i'm swooping in
now the thing that i really loved about
this room
was the wood okay and i know that there
is a certain painting that's very
important to you
that actually has a nautical theme and
wood plays into nautical yep so let's
work with the wood in your room okay
i find the tones a little masculine okay
um you know they're sort of with the the
valances at the top of the curtains the
dark pillows the dark
chair there's some sort of masculine
aesthetics going on okay
and i think a little feminine little
lighter
colors okay would work nicely okay i
think that sounds good
well um we wanted to actually uh
surprise you
so this was your bedroom
okay this is your bedroom now
[Music]
and the sale no
you go over there to that side
oh my wow wow
everything in this room is yours oh my
god
this is incredible
oh my god this is amazing i have to say
i thought the painting worked really
well over the bed but i
wanted the chi to maybe it was right in
front of you
every day so i thought it was whereas
this
might be a glance over and a little bit
more of something you fall into as a
voluntary
choice rather than the everyday
immediate hit
um i specifically placed mirrors over
here because of the incredible
accomplishment of losing
75 pounds i'd love it you need a mirror
over your dresser and you need a full
length to say like
look at what i've done and see yourself
that's awesome
truly see yourself we did sconces
over the bed so that you'd have more
space on your bedside table because
lamps always monopolize all the table
space
yes i had like books holding up my lamps
before i fell in love with this company
serena and lily
and they have this beachy quality about
them that to me was
so transportive every time i would see
their stuff
it took me on holiday and they are who
did all of this with us
this is amazing and lily that is amazing
and um and then we know that you have
good taste
they're incredible and the nicest
company and
um so they are gifting all of this
and serena and lily has taken care of
that and then the mattress was provided
by lisa sleep and it's a king-size
hybrid mattress
wow very nice awesome it's amazing lisa
also because of all your wood in your
room i thought like a nice bamboo red
tan
but we had no time and three day blind
swooped in and we're like we're doing it
for you
and then mr handyman which
sounds like a really fun company um mr
handyman is gonna paint your room
because we thought in out with the
purple in with the new
and they're also going to repair there's
a little water damage on the ceiling
they're going to do that
yeah oh my god yeah that's all done
this is incredible unbelievable
i can't i can't thank you
thank you to all those people you just
mentioned and
yeah this is awesome this is really cool
and i'm
really happy with this like it totally
this is my
this is what i thought when i bought
that painting someday it's gonna work in
this room and it
it works it works it's awesome this is
incredible
i think that when you are surrounded in
some type of serenity
and beauty and that can come at very
different prices for everyone
this is not a matter of economics it's a
matter of
trying to have the care
for your mental and spiritual wellness
to be in a space that you feel good
about
it's incredible thank you karen thank
you
[Music]
you